so these are all miniature environments
that were shot really golem his facial
performance was entirely keyframe the
water in the shot my mind there's a
couple of big advances we made for this
film
thanks to Squarespace for sponsoring
this video
stick to the end to see how you can save
10% on your first purchase hey what's up
welcome back to another episode of
visual effects artists react today we
have a very special guest you may have
seen him in our previous episode talking
about in-game we have Matt aching with
us today Matt joins us from what a
digital in today's episode I think we
want to talk about some of the older
movies that you have worked on and some
of the advances that what a digital has
made over the course of the last you
know 25 years you started working at
wedid there's basically just you and one
other person doing the effects right
yeah that's right so you're like as og
what I've seen we're to be lots of
different variations along the way go
way back to the early days of the
company the film project they really put
us on the map was Lord of the Rings the
work was in a lot of ways much more
difficult because there was a lot more
character work one of the things I found
amusing from looking at the behind the
scenes to lower the Rings was how much
entertainment Peter derived from the
turnovers when he would give you guys a
really hard shot to figure out oh yeah
sort of present these shots and just see
how many dropped jaws you can get out of
one of these turnovers I'm sure the roto
artists most suffer psychological
problems the thing I think about Peter
is that he set up with a digital because
he recognized very early on that it was
going to be a really useful tool for him
to make the kind of films that he liked
to make they always had a big visual
effects component he's never really felt
like an outsider to us he's always been
part of the process yeah
what do you think was the biggest
generational leap between Lord of the
Rings Gollum and Hobbit gone Lord of the
Rings Gollum his facial performance was
entirely keyframed like we didn't have
facial motion capture at all when it's
Smeagol having a conversation with
Gollum and he's going back and forth
yeah that's all hand animated to match
Andy Serkis performance yeah there's no
automated tests Hydra no 32 different
control they're just keyframing you know
between zero and one the facial
component would take a good two weeks to
do for like maybe a two second shot you
know typical to two and a half second
one so there's a lot of painstaking work
going on there really crafting it Andy
will have been on set with these guys
clambering around he's very athletic and
he we painted him out of every every
shot that golems in this is his own
painting because he tends to poke out
around the edges of Gollum and heed the
motion capture on a motion-capture stage
at a separate time that we incorporated
into these plates it must've been really
difficult for Andy and one of the Rings
to kind of do this all this work on the
motion capture stage when Elijah wasn't
there and he was just basically you know
working to an audio track but by the
time we got to the Hobbit we were able
to on sit motion capture simultaneous
with a libation photography including
the facial motion capture it was a much
more active friendly approach
the world premiere for the third Lord of
the Rings film was actually in
Wellington New Zealand where we are
based we had a great party afterwards
then I checked my own box and Peter had
a King Kong meeting scheduled for 8
o'clock the next morning yeah let's keep
going like half the party yeah sleep in
the next day we were all bored with it
we were to keep going as well nice King
Kong was like a really fantastic project
to work on as in the CGI and his movie
looks like a movie from 10 years after
its time I mean there's a couple of big
advances we made for this film we got
fur going that was one of the big
challenges we hadn't really done fur to
this level before and we were doing
facial motion capture for the first
episode Andy Serkis who did the
reference performance become unlike save
for Gollum here we're actually driving
Kong's facial performance
it was one of the biggest challenges you
guys face for the sequence
well this looking back on this what what
occurs to me you know the time of King
Kong we couldn't do the complex natural
environment of an island based jungle we
couldn't do that on the computer so
these are all military environments that
were shot really yeah with motion
control camera moves these are some fast
camera moves going on yeah no because
we've got a motion control camera we can
repeat the camera move on the miniature
over and over again with multiple passes
key light passes fill that passes fog
passes Oh interesting
you guys can alter those after the fact
and because light is additive you know
you can just take those passes and add
them together in your cob it's just as
simple as yep yep it's except we're
getting whatever flexibility we can out
of the setup so there's a lot of
compositing work going into this yeah
it's even just to get the environment
before you put the creatures in so you
have to do is casting a shadow from the
CG characters onto this real environment
trying to make them feel like they're
really connected exactly we've laser
scanned the miniature so we've got that
as geometry that we are using as
reference
like when Kong's hanging off the cliff
we need to know where the military is
we're using the same meat-packing
scanner yeah pretty much I've been
there's particle-like simulations for
interaction with leaves and some of
that's a land-based and some of its
simulation based I think we should talk
about comms death so another spoiler
Kondo sorry people
one of the ways that we work really hard
to make our characters seem alive is by
the way we light their eyes we'll get
make sure that we get a nice high light
in the eyes and that's often a cheated
light that we have to bring in we had
this moment where calm dies and one of
the ways that we let the audience know
subtly that he has actually died is that
we turn those all those light passes off
and I think I think if you know that
that's that's happening you actually get
to see it it's like his eyes are drying
out so that people are consciously aware
of that but I think they emotionally
will respond to what that what that
means that's really fascinating I was
getting excited when there's a an effect
that's something that anybody could do
and it brings like emotional power with
it King Kong themselveses hair
simulations and skins
capture but there are questions in the
eye disappearing that's the key to the
short I think that's what really makes
it yeah do any more like favorite
characters like dying that you want
those moments we could talk about Spidey
bluffing out at the end of and put
ourselves through enough already you
want to see more of these videos
consider subscribing that's the best way
to make sure you don't miss out on an
episode these are fun to do and I bet
there's a shot that's inspired you or a
shot that you like how is this done the
particular scene that sticks in my mind
is the Jurassic Park t-rex on the ride
it still holds up you know it's just
it's just amazing work so they're using
a really clever shader to simulate the
flow of water off the back of the t-rex
here a shader it describes the
interaction of light with the surface of
an object whatever the material is so
the fact that the surface of this t-rex
looks like whit riptile skin that's the
shader doing there I was doing my
masters in computer graphics when
Jurassic Park came out and I went to
that with my wife and a good buddy
and they were like oh that was that was
cool that was fun I was like don't you
realize what we just saw it's all change
speaking of amazing visual effects do
you have one that you want us to take a
look at leave a comment down below we'll
read it and maybe in the very next
episode we'll take a look abbit are was
the highest-grossing movie of all time
until your most recent movie came out
I think we did about 90% of the shots I
helped in a pre-production context so
it's so kind of building the world the
jungle environments in Avatar where it
was CG yeah and there were no miniatures
shot for um for a litera doll so that
represents a huge change and the way
that in general filmmakers approach
because it wasn't just us it was
everybody was making that same
transition at that time this shot right
here I spoke about this another VFX
artists react the water in the shot blew
my mind I saw had never seen water like
it before it was certainly of the bits
water we're done I think we continue to
get better at this stuff it's all done
in CG the simulation includes foam
passes includes a sense of aeration
which has bubbles micro bubbles in the
water so you get that kind of foaming
and clouding of the water so you it's
not just like a clear volume that really
aids the sense of looking like real
water so I do have one scene in
particular from Avatar that kind of blew
me away
[Music]
it's one thing to have like digital
actors interacting with real actors but
the Navi are are very tall they're way
taller than two lenses so she is
interacting with the real play
photography of Jake solely here and
maintaining correct eye lines putting
things on his face this may be one of
the scenes that we shot with the system
we called Simon
we have motion control happening on a
separate stage but adjacent to the
live-action stage at the same time as
principal so Jim can actually see on a
monitor he can see Zoe playing Neytiri
she might have like a scaled-down
version of Jake like as a dummy that
she's holding you'll have grips or
stunts he's you know moving Jake her out
moving Sam around as Jake and he can
kind of frame up on them both of them
because he's got he's got a monitor that
combines the CG and a theory that's
being driven in real time by Zoe's
performance it means that the shots can
feel very natural as if he's actually
there filming and he can give notes to
both of them at the same time some of
this is probably digital Jake as well
yeah like his hand there's probably
digital I think it would have to be yes
you get that level of interaction are
you guys currently working on the next
avatar movies can you even talk about
that I think I can I think I I can the
first two sequels they're concentrating
on those two now so avatar 2 and avatar
3 we're also working on the film's in
pre-production kind of context at where
the digital developing kind of
revolutionary stuff actually which I
don't think I can go into people should
watch out for because there's some
pretty amazing stuff for very high-end
new stuff going on for these films
[Music]
you
hi I'm Jake Watson will you be an angel
for yourself every day thousands of
people go without their own beautiful
award-winning website losing friends
clients and opportunities but thanks to
today's sponsor Squarespace there's hope
take my friend Ren over here before
Squarespace he had no access to traffic
overview web site analytics or anything
else of that nature his web site was
just sitting out there on the open
Internet blind but now thanks to
Squarespace he's looking at those
analytics every day one of the most
tragic stories I ever heard was about my
friend Dean tried to build a website of
his own but didn't have 24/7
award-winning customer service and as a
result kept waiting days helped with
Squarespace and their customer service
he found out the answer within minutes
did I mention their beautiful
award-winning templates oh you see
Griffin back there you probably see him
back there he's always back there it's
the guy with the long hair sadly one
time he was out of town and he wanted to
make a change to his website but he
didn't have Squarespace so he couldn't
just call one of his co-workers and ask
him to make the change through
squarespace's multiple contributors tool
now being angel in your own life and let
other friends clients and opportunities
come to you with your own beautiful
award-winning lips just go to
squarespace.com slash corridor group and
remember with Squarespace there's always
hope for your webs
don't worry buddy they're coming don't
worry
[Music]
Matt it's been an absolute pleasure and
absolute honor having you here with us
thank you so much for coming on the show
sharing some of your knowledge and your
experiences with everyone and it's due
to people like you that we have these
amazing images that we get to look at on
screen and these you know these stories
that bring us to worlds that we
otherwise never get to see thank you so
much for taking the time to come out
here to stop by our little studio and
sit on our green leather couch I feel
like we gained just a tiny fraction of
some legitimacy by having you here like
glad to contribute one of the things I
love about this field and one of the
reasons where I guess I'm still working
in after 25 or 30 years is that it's
constantly evolving and with us
constantly evolving but also the field
is constantly changing and we're
developing new techniques and we kind of
I like to think we're getting better at
what we do and filmmakers are always
telling us new challenges as well so
it's constantly stimulating and
interesting for me yeah